The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
HONG LIU: So last time, we
talked about-- we introduced
the concept of D-branes.
And then we quantized open
strings on the D-branes.
And we see the massive
spectrum on the D-branes
includes, say,
massless gauge field,
and also some massless
scalar fields.
And then I described
that one can interpolate
the dynamics of
the scalar fields
actually as the motion
of the D-branes.
So in other words,
at the beginning,
even when we quantize
the open string,
we started with a rigid
boundary condition,
so we started with a rigid ring.
But now, after you quantize it,
then you get the fluctuations.
And because of
those fluctuations,
the D-branes become dynamical.
Those fluctuations
of the D-branes
make it into a dynamic
object in principle
to make it move, or et cetera.
So now let's say a
little bit regarding
the math of a D-brane.
In the gravitational
theory, anything gravitates.
D-brane will have energy.
It will have a mass, et cetera.
so let's talk about what
should be the mass of a D-brane
if it's a dynamic object.
So here, there's a very
simple and intuitive answer.
So on the D-brane, there
are many open strings.
In principle, there
are an infinite number
of open string excitations
live on the D-brane.
And each of them can
be considered, say,
as a space time field living
on the D-brane, et cetera.
So actual definition for
the mass of a D-brane
is that this should be the
energy of a D-brane, which
essentially should be the ground
state, the energy of the ground
state of the D-brane.
The energy of the ground
state of a D-brane
could be corresponding to the
energy of the D-brane none
of those strings are excited.
That should correspond
to the vacuum energy
of open strings living on it.
So this is very
intuitive definition
and obviously makes sense.
So we can write the mass
of a D-brane, DP-brane,
as the tension, which
is the mass per unit
volume times the total volume.
And this should be
equal to the vacuum
energy of all the open strings.
So say each open string
excitation corresponding
to a field.
You have a tachyon.
You have gauge field.
You have massive
scalar field, and also
infinite number
of massive fields.
All those fields, they
have vacuum energy.
So you need to sum
all of them together.
The sum of those
vacuum energies would
be the mass of the D-brane.
So this can be achieved
just by doing the vacuum
diagram of open strings.
So we describe in the
closed stream case,
if you want to find the vacuum
energy in the closed string,
you just sum of all possible.
So this will be just
the vacuum diagram.
In other words,
so the difference
between the open string is
that open strings have boundary
and closed strings are closed.
So that means the sum of
all two dimensional surfaces
with this one boundaries but
no external open strings.
This is the natural definition
of the vacuum diagram,
as we would do.
And we will do in the
Euclidean path integral.
So you can do this in the
You sum over all surfaces.
In the case when you need
the sum of all surfaces,
in some sense, the only way we
know how to define such a sum
is to do the Euclidean
path integral.
And this sum-- so previously,
we talked about the vacuum
energy of the closed
stream, the sum
of all possible closed surfaces,
say of different topology.
So here, again, you sum
of all possible surfaces
with this one boundaries.
So the simplest surface
with one boundary is a disk.
The difference with
closed string case,
now you have to sum over
surfaces with boundaries.
So the simplest one
would be a disk.
And the next would be annulus.
Now you have two boundaries
rather than one boundary.
And exactly you can consider
more and more complicated
diagrams.
You can consider more and
more complicated diagrams.
And the way to weight those
surfaces exactly the same
as before is that you
have this g string
than to the power
minus chi, and the chi
is the Euler number, just
exactly as we described before.
And Euler number now to apply
surfaces with boundaries
would be-- so previously,
Euler number is 2 minus 2h.
h is number of genuses,
or number of holes.
But now you also need to include
the number of boundaries,
which are called b.
So when you include
the boundaries,
then that will change
your Euler number,
and also change the
weight for each diagram.
You can also add handles here.
You can also add
genuses to the disk.
You can also add h here.
So according to this
counting, then this
would count as gs minus 1.
So this one has zero
holes and one boundaries.
So this is 2 minus 1.
So this is 1.
So this is gs to the
power negative 1.
And this one has low
hole but two boundaries.
2 minus 2 is 0.
This is 1 to the
power gs to the 0.
And then you have
higher diagrams.
You have higher surfaces
with all positive powers, gs.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: What about
like a Mobius strip
that has one boundary?
HONG LIU: Right.
So the Mobius strip is
a very good question.
A Mobius strip is
unoriented surface.
So here, we can see
the oriented string.
You can consider
unoriented string.
But most of what we said
applies to that case.
It's just we have to worry a
little bit about orientation,
so we don't go there.
AUDIENCE: Will that
really contribute
to the vector [INAUDIBLE]?
HONG LIU: Hm?
AUDIENCE: Will the Mobius
strip contribute to the--
HONG LIU: Yeah, yeah, it will.
In the case when you
have unoriented string.
AUDIENCE: But you make
a restriction and say,
on this D-brane, we have
or not have unoriented--
HONG LIU: Here, we only
consider oriented surfaces.
We only consider
oriented strings.
We have not talked about
unoriented strings.
AUDIENCE: But no
restriction in principle.
HONG LIU: You can.
It's actually a
technical complication
I don't want to
go into right now.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So we think of
vertical axis as time.
So the disk would
be a string kind
of nucleating and propagating--
HONG LIU: No.
This is a Euclidean and
you can think of time
as whatever you want.
AUDIENCE: Right.
But still, so the disk would be
like a nucleating open string
that propagates and
then disappears, right?
HONG LIU: Yeah.
For example, this open
string you can consider.
Heuristically, you
may be able to think
of some kind of a single string,
just rotate, for example.
AUDIENCE: Like forever?
HONG LIU: Yeah.
For example, I
just said a single.
I'm just saying it's hard
to interpret as a time now.
But the time in this direction
would be periodic time
if you think from
that point of view.
But the good thing
is that when you
go to Euclidean, what you call
time and the spatial direction
then becomes obscured.
It depends on your convenience.
AUDIENCE: In the
center, is that a genus?
HONG LIU: No.
The center is completely smooth.
AUDIENCE: It's not like a torus?
HONG LIU: No.
A disk is a disk.
A disk is not a torus.
AUDIENCE: But there's a--
HONG LIU: You're
talking about this one?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
HONG LIU: Oh.
This one is annulus.
This guy is annulus.
This is a flat surface.
AUDIENCE: So the inside
and outside are the--
HONG LIU: They are different.
If you identify this and that,
then they become a torus.
When you identify
this one and that one,
then they become a torus.
Then you get rid
of the boundaries.
When you identify them, then
there's no boundary anymore
because they become a circle.
Good?
So that means if I have
weak coupling, that
means when gs is much smaller
than 1, which is the cases we
can only consider because if
you have gs more than 1, then
you have some infinite
number of diagrams.
And we don't know how
to deal with this.
So weak coupling, when gs more
than 1, then the brane tension,
then the D-brane
will be always scaled
with string coupling at 1
over gs because of that,
because this term will dominate.
This term will dominate.
And then the energy
should be 1 over gs.
This is a very important result.
It's a very important result.
The mass of the D-brane
is actually 1 over gs.
So on dimensional ground, you
can just essentially write down
what's the tension
of the D-brane
because the only dimensional
parameter is alpha prime.
So the dimension of
the D-brane should
be-- so this is mass
per unit volume.
So you have a p
dimension of volume, then
that would be p plus 1.
So the mass dimension of the
tension would be p plus 1.
So just on dimension
ground, I can write gs
because it's 1 over s,
alpha prime 1/2 p plus 1.
So that gives you
the right dimension.
And then you can have
some numerical constant
which you need to determine.
You have some numerical
constant which
you can determine string theory
by doing that path integral.
Any questions about this?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Do these open
string vacuum diagrams
have any interpretations
like half of a closed string
diagram?
So if you put two disks
together, you have a sphere.
HONG LIU: Right.
We will talk about
this in a minute.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: With the
logical decomposition
of the powers of g, why
is the disk g minus 1.
HONG LIU: This comes
from this formula.
As we discussed before, the
weight of different topology
is always weighted by some
constant to the power of Euler
number.
Now, the Euler number, if you
have surfaces with boundaries,
then the Euler number depends
on the number of boundaries.
And then you can
just work it out.
So this is based
on simple topology.
Any other questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I'm sorry.
I'm just a little bit confused
about the vacuum energy
here as the one-- remember
when you calculate
the mass of the string.
You know, we have a
naught term there.
There is no excitation.
HONG LIU: Sorry.
Say it again.
AUDIENCE: So when we calculate
the mass of the open string
and there is a0 term, which
is completely different.
HONG LIU: That's
completely different.
So that a0, we
considered before, it's
the zero point energy
for the oscillation
modes on the screen.
So that a0 is that
we are considering
this string, and the zero point
energy for the oscillation
mode on this string.
But here, we are
considering the zero point
energy not of the string.
We are considering the zero
point energy of the D-brane.
And the zero point
energy of the D-brane
would be to write down the
vacuum energy of all the fields
living on the D-brane.
And all the fields living
on the D-brane corresponding
to all the-- now,
each string excitation
becomes a field on the D-brane.
And so that's corresponding
to sum of that.
And that, then, in
turn corresponding
to sum of these
kind of surfaces.
Any other questions?
So there's an
alternative way to think
about how to compute
the D-brane mass
or energy as follows, which is
actually extremely instructive.
There is an alternative
way of doing this.
So let's consider just D-brane.
So consider the interaction
between the two D-branes.
So let's consider two D-branes
separated by some distance.
And then they have a mass.
Then they will interact
gravitationally.
In particular, in a
weak coupling limit
they're pretty massive.
They're very massive because
it's 1 over the g string.
So when g string is small,
which is the only regime
we're working with, so
the D-brane is very heavy.
And so you can ask, what is
the gravitational attraction
between the two?
What is the interaction
And we know that
at low energies,
say if the two D-branes
are not excited,
if their distance
are very far apart,
then the leading
interaction between them
just comes from
the massless mode
because only massless mode
mediates normal interactions.
And so interaction
between them just
comes from graviton
or this [INAUDIBLE],
essentially just corresponding
to small number of massless
closed string modes.
Only those massless
modes will contribute
because the massive mode
only contributes short range
interactions.
AUDIENCE: Why not the
vector mode in open string?
HONG LIU: No.
Vector mode of open string
only lives on each brane.
AUDIENCE: But we can have
an open string like--
HONG LIU: I will talk
about that separately.
Just wait a little bit.
So if I think purely from
the alternative gravity
point of view, not from
string theory point of view,
I have two massive objects.
I want to look at the
interaction between them.
And then interaction will
be proportional to gn,
say their mass.
So if I factor out
the volume factor,
it would be just GN TP squared.
So this essentially is the
gravitational interaction
between the two.
And from the string
theory point of view,
such a diagram
corresponding to you
exchange your closed string.
So this diagram
corresponding says,
suppose you have
brane one, brane two.
So this picture that brane
one will emit graviton
absorbed by the other brane.
And then that's how we
measure, say, the newtons
force between them.
And it translates to the
string theory picture.
This corresponding to one
D-brane emits a closed string,
and then absorbed by
the other D-brane.
And when you go to
[INAUDIBLE], which
only massless mode matters,
and then becomes this picture.
So this is the string theory
version of that diagram.
So now essentially,
what you need
to do to calculate this
thing in the string theory
is to calculate this
thing in the diagram.
So form the string
theory point of view,
now what you need to consider
is to do path integral
on the topology of
a cylinder with one
boundary on the brane one
and the other boundary
on brane two.
So this corresponds to
exchange of a closed
string in this direction.
AUDIENCE: Question.
HONG LIU: Yes?
AUDIENCE: What's the mechanism
for the D-brane emitting
a closed string?
Or equivalently, on
the other picture,
why can it emit a graviton?
HONG LIU: It's
coupled to graviton.
AUDIENCE: So how did we
introduce the coupling?
HONG LIU: Hm?
AUDIENCE: How did we
introduce the coupling?
I mean, we introduced them
as boundary conditions
for open strings.
HONG LIU: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So does that
naturally introduce coupling?
HONG LIU: No, no, no.
This is what I'm writing here.
And this diagram, you emit from
a closed string corresponding
to look at the cylinder.
One boundary of the cylinder on
the location with one D-brane,
and the other boundary of
the cylinder on the location
of the other D-brane.
And then you just integrate
over this surface.
And then that will give
you the graviton exchange.
That will give you
the closed string
exchange between the two.
AUDIENCE: So the coupling of the
closed string to the brane kind
of naturally arises?
HONG LIU: In the boundary
condition imposed here.
So you impose this closed
string to initiate it
from-- so you impose the
boundary condition here
so that this closed string
starts from brane one
and then ends on brane two.
And then you integrate
over all surfaces
this cylinder topology.
AUDIENCE: We know the
interaction constant
for closed string is g closed,
but is it the same here?
HONG LIU: No.
That's what I'm
going to talk about.
Is this clear?
OK.
So now I'm going to
mention two things.
First, as I said
before, whenever
we do some calculations, we
often do analytic integration
to the Euclidean signature.
So now it will be the same.
When we do this calculation,
we have a closed string start
at location of the brane
one, and move forward
in time to end on the brane two.
So this is the simplest diagram.
You can also add
some holes here.
And then that corresponds to
higher order diagram structure.
So now don't worry about that.
Just the simplest diagram.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Was it time
dimension inside brane
to define time dimension
as one of the dimensions
that lived inside brane?
HONG LIU: Yeah.
But this is not a
space time [INAUDIBLE].
This is virtual time.
This is virtual time
associated with this graviton.
So essentially, I do create
the closed string here
on this brane and then
propagate then absorbed
by the other D-brane.
AUDIENCE: Can you also
think about this as
like an open string--
HONG LIU: Yeah.
One second.
I'm going to explain.
So now there are two remarkable
things about this diagram.
The two remarkable things
about this diagram.
First, this is a
cylinder diagram.
And this is a diagram
with two boundaries
because we have to emit a
closed string from here.
And so you have one boundary.
You have an initial
closed string,
then you have a
final closed string.
So this is a surface with
two boundaries with no holes.
And if you calculate the
chi, so this would be zero.
Then that means this
diagram is gs to power of 0.
And then from here,
we know that then
this from string
theory point of view
will be gs to the power of 0.
And so this is another way
to see that the TP should
be 1 over g string.
Because we said before
that the G Newton--
so we explained before G Newton
would be order of gs squared.
G Newton is the
g string squared.
So do you remember G
Newton is g string squared?
Good.
But something remarkable
about this diagram
is that you can also
view this diagram.
So right now, we see
it from this direction.
Now we can also view it
from the other direction.
Viewed from this
direction, so now
try to think about
this direction
as the time and this
direction as the sigma.
So right now, we are
seeing this as virtual time
and this as sigma.
This is a closed string.
So now think about
this direction as sigma
and this direction as time.
And then this is an open
string with one end ending
on brane two and the other
end ending on brane one,
and then going in the loop.
So this is the one
loop open string.
So even though this
is tree-level exchange
in closed string.
So here is the tree-level
exchange in closed string.
So here is one loop
in open string.
So this tells you
the same process.
You can really view it
from two perspectives.
From one perspective, it's
the standard point of view,
is that we exchange
some closed strings.
So we exchange some gravitons,
some massless particles,
some particles
between these two.
But there's another way to
think about it is we say,
because we have
two D-branes here
and because D-branes correspond
in two places, open string
can end, then I have open
string connect between them.
And this one loop open
string is essentially
corresponding to the vacuum
diagram of those open strings
connect between them.
So when you add
the vacuum energy
of all those open strings
ending between them,
then you're effectively
calculating the interaction
between the two D-branes.
So we have two completely
different perspectives
to look at the same process.
And this is very, very
deep and profound.
Deep is profound.
Because that means
the process that you
can think from closed
string perspective
can be fully understood
in a different way
from the open
string perspective,
in a completely equivalent way.
And this is normally
called the channel duality.
So it's a very
simple geometric fact
about two dimensional surfaces.
But physical significance
is very profound.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
HONG LIU: One second.
Let me finish.
And this is precisely
the string theory
origin of the holographic
duality or the idea, say, of t
we are going to see in
a couple of lectures.
Just because of this
simple geometric picture.
This side is gravity, and the
D-brane is about gauge theory.
And then we see gravity to be
equivalent to gauge theory.
That's something we
are going to see later.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So you said the
dynamics of closed string
can be fully understood
by open string.
Is that why you say
it's a closed surface
formed by a closed string?
How can you interpret?
HONG LIU: Yeah.
I'm talking about this
particular diagram.
I'm just saying this gives
you a hint of something
very profound.
AUDIENCE: And one more thing.
Why is the gs 0?
HONG LIU: No.
This is the surface
of two boundaries.
AUDIENCE: But that
is for open string.
HONG LIU: No.
Chi is for everything.
Chi is everything.
Doesn't matter open
or closed string.
This is the universal formula.
This is open.
The open string just means we
imposed the boundary condition
on the open string.
The topology is the same.
We understand the
topology is the same.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Why do you
call it one loop string?
Where is the loop?
HONG LIU: Because this
is the open string.
So this is the open.
Think from this point of view.
This is the open string on
brane one and brane two.
And then you go around
once, go around in circle.
So this is one loop.
AUDIENCE: What's
the free momentum?
HONG LIU: What is this?
What is this?
This is one loop if
you have a particle.
And so you have a string.
Then you go around the circle.
This is one loop.
And indeed, when you
sum over such surfaces,
you will lead to sum of all
possible momentums, et cetera.
So the field theory
momentum is one
of the modes you
have to sum over
when you do past integral
over surface of such topology.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Once you go to strings
connecting different branes,
your quantization
conditions change.
HONG LIU: We will
talk about that.
Quantization condition
almost does not change.
We will talk about that.
We'll talk about
that in a little bit.
But right now, it's
just intuitively
clear you have open string
connect between them
and they just go around.
You have open string
connect between them.
You can just go
around the circle.
AUDIENCE: But this
correspondence
doesn't count the tree-level
around the open string.
HONG LIU: Count what?
AUDIENCE: If we generalize
the tree-level open string.
HONG LIU: No, no, no.
This doesn't have to account
for the tree-level open string.
AUDIENCE: Tree-level open string
contributes to the interaction?
HONG LIU: No.
Here, I'm only talking
about this diagram
and just say this
hints that there
are certain closed string
processes can be completely
described by the open string.
So what want to extrapolate
is that open string
is a more fundamental
description
because the tree-level
diagram in closed string
can be described
by the open string.
And now if you can generalize
that maybe everything closed
string can be described
by open string.
But you don't want to
do in the opposite way.
Open string is open string.
Good?
Any other questions?
AUDIENCE: Once you
go higher dimensions,
when you leave tree-level
closed string can be distinct?
HONG LIU: Yes.
Things become more complicated.
But the similar
picture will exist.
But nobody has made it work.
Nobody has made it work at
full string theory level
to construct the whole
closed string theory
from the open string theory.
Nobody has made it work.
But there are many such kind of
indications from the geometry
of the surface point of view.
So now let's talk about relaxing
the strength of open string
interactions.
Actually, before I do
that, now is a good place
to go back to examine
what we discussed
at the end of last lecture.
Now is a good time to go back
to talk about what we did
at the end of the last lecture.
So in the last
lecture, at the end,
we described that
one can work out
the low energy effective
action of the massless modes
on the D-branes.
So the massless modes on
the D-branes on the gauge
fields along the D-brane,
so A alpha from 0, 1, to p.
And then the scalar field and
a label all the perpendicular
directions.
So you can write down
effective action for them.
I mentioned if you work
out things carefully,
then you find the
prefactor is actually
just the brane tension.
And if last thing is
excited, p plus 1.
If last thing is
excited, then you just
have the vacuum energy,
so you will have a one.
So this is just the brane
mass, the total brane mass.
This is et.
So if last thing is
excited, then you just
have the zero
point energy, which
is just tp times the volume.
But now, if you also
have gauge field, then
based on general argument,
you must have the Maxwell.
And if the scalar
field is excited,
then you also have the action
for massless scalar field.
And then we mentioned
that for example, you
can consider special case.
Suppose A alpha is not excited
but the brane, rather than
a scalar field that
moves in a coherent way
the same at all points on
the D-brane, just phi a,
is a function of
t rather than x.
So phi, in general.
Suppose the brane
coordinates our x0 and the p.
So in general, A alpha is
the function of x0, xp.
And phi a is x0 and xp.
So they describe you can
have arbitrary profile
on the world-volume.
But suppose, say, let me
consider the uniform situation
which I only consider
every point has
the same behavior for phi.
And then this s just becomes
1/2, dt just becomes dt.
And D-brane plus 1/2 and
D-brane phi dot squared.
So this is precisely the motion
of just a massive object.
OK And m is just this guy.
So if last thing depends
on the spatial coordinate,
then the integration of
the spatial coordinate
becomes the volume.
Combine the volume with
that, becomes the mass,
and then just becomes that.
I think this is minus sign.
This is plus sign.
So as I mentioned,
this is another way
to see that the D-brane
becomes dynamical,
and that in particular,
this phi describes
the motion of the D-brane.
So in fact, this result can
be much, much strengthened.
But I will only
quote the result.
I will only quote the result.
It turns out for
D-brane with constant.
So as opposed to the D-brane
move with constant velocity,
so now you can
also have a motion
in the spatial direction.
You have a constant of
this and F alpha beta.
You can also excite
the gauge field,
but the field
strength is constant.
Or this quantity is small.
They don't have to
be strictly constant,
but at least their
derivatives are small.
In such a situation,
one can actually
sum all the higher order terms
from string theory corrections.
So this is just a low energy,
just like field theory.
And in such a situation,
you can actually
sum over infinite number
of higher order terms.
And what do you find?
You find so-called wave sum
of all infinite number higher
terms.
You find so-called
Dirac-Born-Infeld action.
You find that this effective
action becomes like this.
This is very [INAUDIBLE] result.
So I just want to mention it.
You can actually
sum into this form.
So you can sum into this form.
And this g alpha beta
is the [INAUDIBLE].
So let me just explain
a little bit the physics
of this formula.
So let's consider
the case of the phi
is not excited at all,
just phi for the constant,
say, for example.
Then this term vanishes.
Then this g alpha beta just
becomes eta alpha beta.
And now you just
have a square root,
say, your Minkowski
metric plus F alpha beta.
Forget about this
2 pi alpha prime.
This is just some
dimensional factor.
And then you just have eta
alpha beta plus F alpha beta.
And then you write
the determinant.
And suppose when F alpha beta is
small, when alpha prime times F
alpha beta is small,
then you can expand it
in powers of F alpha beta.
It's a simple exercise
but instructive exercise.
You see that precisely
reproduces the Maxwell term.
But this will give rise
to higher nonlinear terms.
There will be higher
order nonlinear terms.
So this can be considered as
a nonlinear generalization
of the Maxwell theory.
It turns out
actually, this theory
was considered in the '30s
by this guy, Born and Infeld.
Actually, maybe '30s or '40s.
Anyway, prehistory.
They invented as a
way to avoid-- they
want to avoid the similarity
of the Maxwell theory.
So in the Maxwell theory, if
you have a charged particle,
and then the location
of the charged particle,
then the field due
to that charged
particle is singular and the
location of that particle.
And so they want to avoid
that singular behavior,
so they invented this
Born-Infeld action.
And for many years, this action
does not have any applications.
But if you invent something
nice, it will find its use.
Just like in this
movie, Jurassic Park,
life finds a way.
Life always finds a way.
So that's Born-Infeld.
Now let's set F equal to 0.
Let's just look at g alpha beta.
Now let's look at g alpha beta.
So g alpha beta, we can write it
in a slightly more transparent
form.
We can write a form which makes
it a bit more transparent.
I can write it as the following.
So even mu, remember,
is the Minkowski metric
of the full space time.
And I can write
this as following.
x mu beta x mu x mu with
x alpha equal to x alpha,
which is along the brane
direction, and xa to be phi a.
So if you look at
this formula, you
can see this is an induced
metric for some brane embedded
in the full
Minkowski space time.
And the x describes
such embedding.
This generalization of this
induces the metric formula
we encountered before
for the string.
But right now, the
only difference
is that now alpha
beta, they run all
in the world-volume
direction of the D-brane.
And then this becomes
an induced metric
on the D-brane when it's
embedded in the space time.
And this x alpha
equal to x alpha,
it just means that
when we embed it,
and we choose the
world-volume direction
to be the same as the
space time direction
along the brane direction.
And in the perpendicular
direction, this is just phi a.
And if you look at this,
this is exactly that.
It's exactly that because
x alpha equal to x alpha.
And then you just get
the eta alpha beta.
And then for the other
direction, you get this one.
Is this clear?
So when f equal to 0, so this S
just becomes eta g alpha beta.
So this is precisely the
volume element of DB-brane.
Because this is the induced
metric, and then this
is just the total volume
element of the DP-brane.
And we see this is precisely
is the relativistic
generalization.
So this is just a generalization
of the [INAUDIBLE] action
we wrote earlier,
which is for a string.
Then this would be a
two dimensional area.
And here, you just integrate
over the volume element
of the whole D-brane.
So we see that this
Born-Infeld corresponding
to really describes the
relativistic motion of a p
dimensional object.
Describes the relativistic
motion of a p dimensional
object.
And this Dirac-Born-Infeld, when
you combine these two together,
it magically combines these
two things into a single thing.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So I recall
you saying earlier
that-- you said that
people have played
with this idea of
thinking about branes
instead of just generically
higher dimensional objects
and strings but no one
really understood the theory
of these things because
the topology and geometry
were too complicated.
So it seems to me that wouldn't
you run into that same problem
right here if it's indeed
some generalization
of the [INAUDIBLE] action?
HONG LIU: Yeah, but we
don't try to quantize it.
At least we don't try
to quantize this action.
And we know how to
quantize this action.
And this is just our
ordinary field theory.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
Here, we must impose the
big x as the coordinates
in the target space.
HONG LIU: That's right.
AUDIENCE: So phi a must
be kind of a constant?
I mean, why there should
be a constant part on--
HONG LIU: No.
If the derivative of those
things are not small,
then there will be
many other terms.
This will not be
the only action.
AUDIENCE: Given a constant.
HONG LIU: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: You said
with a constant.
HONG LIU: The partial alpha
phi a equal to constant.
AUDIENCE: Oh, equals a constant.
So that means--
HONG LIU: No.
What I'm saying is that if
these are constants, then
this is our exact
string theory action.
And when these
are not constants,
and then this is a
leading approximation,
there will be higher
order terms which
depend on their derivatives.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
One thing I just
don't understand--
why is it that we don't want
to try to quantize anything?
Shouldn't it be
quantized in principle?
These are the sort
of classical analogs
of things you want to quantize.
HONG LIU: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So this is
to say that this object
that we don't really
know how to quantize
is-- we just don't do it
because we don't know how.
HONG LIU: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I see.
OK.
It's not because-- fair enough.
HONG LIU: Yeah.
You should try anything.
And only those people who have
succeeded in the history books.
Only a few have won the
battle in the history books.
And if you just fail the battle,
you're not in the history book.
So people have tried
this but failed it,
but that won't be
written in the books.
AUDIENCE: Sure.
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
So you did the square
root by summing over
all the massive terms in the--
HONG LIU: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: You get
the square root term
by summing the series,
including the massive fields?
HONG LIU: No.
This is still the gauge
field and the phi.
AUDIENCE: Right.
So how do you get it?
What's the series
that you're summing?
HONG LIU: Hm?
AUDIENCE: What's the
series that you're summing?
HONG LIU: Oh.
I'm just saying in
the string theory,
typically you don't
start by f squared.
You have f cubed,
f four, et cetera.
You can sum all
of them together.
Even for the massless mode,
these are just leading terms.
And these terms would be the
smallest number of derivatives,
and so they dominate
at low energies.
But in general, even just
for the effective serial
massless mode, you can have
many, many other terms.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
If we assume that partial
alpha phi a is a constant,
then we can solve out the phi
a is proportional to x alpha.
But how can you
assume they're just
the coordinate in target space?
HONG LIU: No, no.
This is a function of alpha.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
But since it's a
function of x alpha,
why it can be regarded as the
coordinate in target space?
HONG LIU: Sorry.
I don't understand.
AUDIENCE: All the
coordinates should
be independent in target space.
HONG LIU: Sorry.
I don't understand.
They are independent.
These are the
virtual coordinates.
These are the volume
coordinates of D-brane.
And these are the target
space coordinates.
I'm just choosing the
function of the target
space coordinates.
I'm choosing here
just to be identical
to the world-volume coordinate.
And this one I choose
to be some function
of the world-volume coordinate.
Of course I can do that.
Any other questions?
So again, this highlights
that D-brane is really
a dynamical object.
In fact, at low energies, they
move like [INAUDIBLE] motion.
And they actually
move relativistically
if you give enough
velocity, et cetera.
Because of the fluctuations
of the D-brane,
they become a really
full dynamical object.
They have a mass.
They can move around.
And now you can
deform their shape.
If you have enough energy,
you can bend them, et cetera.
You can do whatever you want.
So let me mention
one last thing.
So you may ask,
why somehow those
fields which describe the
motion of the D-brane,
they're corresponding
to the massless modes
on the world-volume
of the D-branes?
Whether this is a
coincidence, or why it somehow
happens to be the massless
mode on the D-brane
which describes the
motion of the D-brane.
So this is not an accident.
This is not an accident.
The reason is
that-- so why modes
describing motions of D-branes
appear as massless modes?
So this is not accident.
So underlying reason, it's
because the underlying
Minkowski space is
translation invariant.
So that means that no matter
where you put the D-brane,
it should be a
well-defined configuration.
Should be a well-defined
configuration no matter where
you put on the D-brane.
Then that means that the
[INAUDIBLE] action for the phi
cannot contain a potential term.
They cannot be potential term.
They should not be, say,
somewhere is the minimum,
somewhere is the
maximum, cannot happen.
Everywhere must be the same.
So it means the dependence
on y can only be derivative.
Can only depend on derivatives.
And of course, at low energies,
if you have derivatives,
then can only be the
massless particle.
So translation invariant.
So this means that any
phi a equal to constant
should be allowed
configurations.
That means cannot
have potential.
So max term is like
a potential for phi.
To say in the fancy words
of Quantum Field Theory
II or Quantum Field Theory III,
that the phi a, in other words,
phi a are the Goldstone
bosons for breaking
translation symmetries.
So previously, Minkowski space
is translation invariant.
And now if you put
a D-brane there,
then you break that
translation symmetry.
The location of the D-brane
breaks that translation
symmetry.
If I even put the
D-brane anywhere,
then that means the
modes, the dynamics
control the location
of the D-brane
must not have any potential,
can only have derivative terms.
So in other words, when
you put the D-brane in,
you spontaneously break
the translation symmetry
on the line in Minkowski space.
So let me mention one thing.
Then we can have a break.
I'll mention one quick thing.
So let me say a few words on
the strength of the open string
interactions.
So previously, we described
that the closed strings, they
interact by such joining
and splitting procedure.
And the strength
here is capped by gs.
So the closed string coupling
is essentially the gs,
which describes such a process.
So if you have an open
string, of course you
have a similar process, just
string ends joined together.
You can join string
ends together.
So here, you really
just have open string.
So now these lines are the
boundaries of open string,
or the endpoints of open string.
So you have two open
strings joined together
from another one.
So let's call this
interaction go
describing the interaction
of the open string.
So the question is, how
is this go related to gs?
And there's a single way
we can figure it out.
So let's consider the
simplest situation.
Just have open string
propagate in time.
Again, this is two
boundaries open string.
We just propagate in time.
Now let's consider a
more complicated process.
So the open string
propagates in time.
So this is just a simple surface
with one initial open string
and one final open string.
And you can see the
complicated process
because we have a
hole in the middle.
So now the string worksheet
is like this, just this part.
We have a hole in the middle.
And this is another
configuration
to have some initial
open string propagate
to some final open string.
So now we know, by counting
we did before described here.
So here, we're
adding one boundary.
We are adding one boundary.
So this adds a boundary.
So that means we must
add a factor of gs.
Because from this formula,
this is g minus chi.
And chi is minus b.
So if we increase one
boundary, then you
increase a factor of gs.
But we can also
view this diagram
as a single open
string comes in.
The opposite of this splits
into two open strings
and then they close together.
So one split operation,
and the one join operation.
So that should
correspond to go squared.
So then this means that
we conclude that gs must
be proportional to go squared.
The open string coupling
strings is the square root
of the closed
string interaction.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: What's the
strength of the process when
closed string becomes open
string and vice versa?
HONG LIU: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: What's the strength
of the process when closed
string becomes and open string?
HONG LIU: Right.
Yeah, you can
consider such process.
Again, you can just
do it by counting
the topology of the surface.
Such process can exist.
OK.
Then let's have a short break.
So what time is it?
It's 38.
When should we start again?
41?
OK, 41.
Let's start at 41.
So we have talked about
D-branes, et cetera.
And we have already seen
some remarkable aspects
of the D-brane,
including this channel
duality between the
closed string exchange
can be considered
open string loop.
And now we are going to see a
lot of magic of the D-brane.
And this comes when you put
several D-branes together.
So normally, our
conventional intuition
says if you find some
particle, say in this case,
you find the D-brane.
So if you put two
particles together,
nothing much really changes.
It's two particles.
Put three particles together.
Not much changes.
It's three particles.
But when you put multiple
D-branes together,
things change a lot in
a very profound way.
So now let's consider
just two D-branes.
So let's consider two D-branes.
Let's consider example.
So let me first just tell
you the naive intuition.
Suppose you have D-brane
one, D-brane two.
So for this one, we
have a u1 gauge field.
For this one, you
Because each one, we have
a gauge field, a Maxwell.
When you put together,
from conventional wisdom,
you say, maybe I just
have two Maxwell.
From conventional
wisdom, you two Maxwell.
Naively, if I put them together,
I just have two Maxwells.
1 plus 1 equal to 2.
But in string theory,
1 plus 1 equal to 4.
It's actually equal to 2.
It's also equal to 2, depending
on how you think about it.
Anyway, one way to think about
it is 1 plus 1 becomes 4.
So to see 1 plus 1
become 4 is very easy.
So let's consider these two
branes on top of each other.
But in order to distinguish
these two branes,
I just separate
them a little bit.
But you should really think
of them on top of each other.
And so now you have
four types of strings.
You can have string going
to 1, 1, going to 2, 2,
then going to 1,
2, going to 2, 1.
So 2, 1 and 1, 2 are different
because the oriented string.
So I put arrow there.
So this is from 1 to 2.
This is from 2 to 1.
So we have four types of
strings-- 1, 1, 1, 2, 2, 1,
2, 2.
AUDIENCE: Why is oriented--
HONG LIU: Hm?
AUDIENCE: Why the 1 to
2, 2 to 1 are different?
HONG LIU: It's because for
this string, sigma 0 here.
For this one, sigma pi there.
For this string, sigma 0 there.
And for this one,
sigma pi there.
Let me just elaborate
on this point.
So suppose I have
a string like this.
Then this string is sigma
0 point ending on 1,
sigma equal to pi ending on 2.
But if I have a
string like that,
then there's a sigma 0 ending
here and sigma pi ending there.
So you have four
types of open strings.
And now if you think
about how we quantize
those strings, and the
four types of open strings,
they actually have
identical spectrum.
Because for all of them,
the boundary conditions
are exactly the same.
Because the boundary
conditions only
know the location
of the D-branes.
So all four types
of open strings
have identical spectrum.
So in other words, each
string excitation--
say this is the state on the
worksheet-- each state becomes
four states because
I can label IJ.
Now suppose I use I and
J to label 1 and the 2.
I and J can be 1 and 2.
So depending on whether this
is 1, 1 string, or 1, 2 string,
or 2, 1 string, or 2, 2 string.
So this is what I said
1 plus 1 equal to 4.
Because naively, you would
say I have two massless modes.
But now I have four.
For example, the massless modes
become four copies of them.
In other words, you can think
each open string excitation a 2
by 2 matrix.
I can use 2 index to label them.
In particular, for example,
the corresponding fields--
so each string excitation
corresponding to some field.
For example, the gauge
field associated with this
now has two index, I
J. And similar with phi
a I J. Of course, this
generalizes immediately
to if you have n branes,
then just becomes n times
n matrices.
So 1 plus 1 plus 1 to
n becomes n squared.
So now let me give some remarks.
So this basic
structure turns out
to be, again, very,
very profound.
Now let me give some remarks.
So there's a reason
I call-- so this
is something with the 2 index.
So of course, you
naturally call it a matrix.
But there's another reason
to think about this really
as a matrix.
It's because the
strings, as we were
doing there, the open
strings, they interact
by joining their ends.
So this naturally leads to--
when those strings interact
with each other, and
those parts naturally
just emerges as a matrix
product, I, J indices.
So it's easy to see.
So let me just draw that.
Let me just do it here
to save some time.
Suppose this is I. This is J.
So this is sigma equal to 0,
sigma equal to pi.
And the sigma equal to
pi joins with stigma 0
to end of the other one.
But of course, if you want
to join them together,
their J's have to be the same.
This is K. Then you go to I,
K. And when they join together,
then you sum of
all possible J's.
Then this is like
a matrix product.
So if I draw it in the
diagram not very well.
Now let me separate I,
J, K to be three things.
But they don't have
to be separated.
I, J, K can also be the same.
But in order to
emphasize this picture is
that you have a string to go
from I to J. Suppose this is I,
this is J, this is
K. Go from I to J,
then from J to K. So
sigma 0, sigma pi.
And the pi end joins
with the sigma 0 end.
And then here, you
get the string.
So that diagram
roughly can also be
think of a diagram like this.
Two strings join into one
string with index I and K.
And the I, K, K can
all be the same.
I just make them different
to make it clear.
And of course, when
you join J together,
you have the sum of them because
they can be in principle all
possible J's.
So it naturally appears
as a matrix product.
Just follows by the nature
of string interaction.
And now there's another
remarkable thing
is that if you can see the phi
a, so the same thing applies
for a alpha applies
to any field.
It's that 1q-- so
this corresponds
to a string with sigma equal
to 0 at 1 and sigma pi.
So this corresponds
to a 1, 2 string.
And then we can also think
about the 2, 1 string.
So it turns out
that these two can
be considered as complex
conjugates of each other
for the following reason.
Again, now let me just
again separate this 1 and 2
to make it clear.
So this is a 1, 2 string.
So this is a 2, 1 string.
So I claim string interactions
defined by this way
have the following symmetry.
So string interactions
described by joining the ends
or splitting the ends have
the following symmetry.
It's that I can associate
each brane by a phase factor.
So I explained to you i theta
I. So I labeled to the brane
and the theta can be some
different-- can be a phase
factor.
And now the rule is
that if the sigma is
equal to 0 and on
that brane, then
I multiply it by the
exponential of i theta I.
And the sigma equal to pi
ends on that brane, ends on I.
Let me write it more explicit.
So if sigma 0 ending
on I, then I multiply
by a phase factor,
exponential i theta I.
And if the sigma equal
to pi factor ending on I,
then I multiply by
exponential minus i theta I.
So let's consider
this operation.
And I claim this operation
is the symmetry of the string
interaction.
So let's first consider if
you just have a single brane.
So if you have a single
brane like this, then just
nothing changes
because you multiply
one end by i theta and the other
by exponential minus i theta,
does not change.
But now, if you have such
kind of interactions,
because the sigma 0 and
sigma pi ends join together,
and they can only join if they
are ending on the same brane,
then those factors
always cancel each other.
And so this would be a symmetry.
Is this clear?
So under this operation, phi
a ending on the same brane
is invariant.
And phi a I J then transforms
by a phase factor theta
I minus theta J of phi
a I J. And the phi a J
I transforms as a factor
minus I theta I minus theta J.
So we can actually think of
them as complex conjugates.
So they're transforming opposite
way under this phase change.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: And this is
because we're considering
them to be u1 branes?
HONG LIU: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Is this because we're
considering them to be u1?
HONG LIU: No.
This is a good point.
I will talk about this more.
Right now, let's think
about each brane separately.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
In principle, can we write
the interaction of open string
with the same note,
J, J by random number?
HONG LIU: Sorry.
What do you mean
by random number?
AUDIENCE: Say it's I, J, K, L.
HONG LIU: No, no, no.
The strings can
only join together
if they're ending
on the same brane.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
OK.
HONG LIU: So the J's
have to be the same.
So this guarantees that
this will symmetry.
Good?
So in this sense, they're
complex conjugates.
And now we can build on
this a little bit further.
So this actually works.
Doesn't matter
whether the branes are
coincident or not coincident.
This is a generally true.
Now let's consider
all the branes
are coincident with each other.
So for coincidental
branes, since branes
are indistinguishable
from each other,
so they are higher
dimensional generalization
of what we call
identical particles.
So if they're
indistinguishable from each,
we can shuffle their indices.
We should have the symmetry
to reshuffle their symmetries.
So whether we call this 1,
1 or this 1, 2 or this 1,
1 should not matter.
So if I combine these two facts,
two observations together,
then when we have n
coincidental branes,
then there's in
fact u(n) symmetry.
If that whole string
interaction is invariant, say
if I have psi, I, J goes to say
U, I, K, U, J, L, star, psi, K,
L. So back here on U
just corresponding to I
reshuffle all the indices.
So I have to do the same to U.
So I reshuffle the two indices
in the same way.
But I have a star here.
It's because of this reason.
Because in some sense,
the sigma 0 and sigma pi,
they're only symmetries if I
multiply opposite phase factor.
I can rewrite this
as a matrix notation.
If you think about
each side as a matrix,
then this is the
symmetry corresponding
to psi U psi dagger.
And the U can be arbitrary
unitary matrices.
So in fact, when you have n
coincidental branes together,
there's u(n) symmetries for
the string interactions.
So to say it in a more
fancy mathematical language
is that each open
string excitation
transforms under the adjunct
representation of this u(n).
So this is like a
join representation.
If you have u(n)
symmetry, then this
is like a join representation.
So on the string worksheet, this
is really a global symmetry.
So it's just a phase factor
associated with each n.
There's nothing.
It's a global symmetry.
But the remarkable thing
is that in the space time,
this becomes a gauge symmetry.
So this tells you, because of
the presence of this u(n) gauge
symmetry and
because of each mode
transforms under a join
representation of some u(n),
that as a space-time
field, they also
must transform under a join
representation of some u(n).
And interpreting the
space-time, then this u(n)
must be a gauge symmetry.
On the worksheet, it's
a global symmetry.
But in space-time-- so
let me just write it down.
In space-time--
or in other words,
in the world volume
of D-branes, this u(n)
must be a gauge symmetry
for the following reason.
Because the only way
we know-- for example,
this gauge field
becomes transformed
under a join representation
of some u(n) symmetry.
And all the excitations
will have this symmetry.
And then the only
way we can make
sense the gauge field
under such symmetry
is that this is a gauge
symmetry and this is the gauge
boson for that symmetry.
Is it clear?
So let me just say it in words.
It must be a gauge symmetry.
And in particular, a alpha I J
must be the corresponding gauge
bosons.
Because this is the only way
we know how to make sense,
because this is the
only way we know
can happen at low energies.
Some gauge fields transformed
as a matrix interact
with each other.
And this can only be
Yang-Mills theory.
And if this is
Yang-Mills theory,
then this must be
a gauge symmetry.
So this is the basic argument.
And at low energies, we
must have Yang-Mills theory.
So something remarkable happens.
So each D-brane, when
we separate them.
is a Maxwell theory.
When you put them together,
they become Yang-Mills theory.
And somehow, they
become non-Rubinian.
And everything comes from,
in the very trivial way
in string theory, you
just count the indicies.
But the physical
implication is profound.
And this can be
confirmed, again,
by just starting
the explicit string
theory scattering amplitude.
You can calculate the scattering
of 3a in string theory.
Then you find it's precisely--
at low energy, precisely given,
but the same vertex as the
Yang-Mills theory, et cetera.
So you can do that.
Then you find the low
energy effective action can
be written as the following.
Some Yang-Mills coupling trace.
Let me just write down
the Yang-Mills theory.
You find the low
energy effective action
can be written in this form.
So this is standard
Yang-Mills field strings
because now everything
is a matrix.
Everything is a matrix.
And both A alpha and phi a
now are embedded in matrices.
So this g Yang-Mills is
the Yang-Mills coupling
which describes how the
gauge fields interact
with each other.
And obviously, this should
be related to the open string
interaction because-- I think
I have already erased it.
This kind of interaction,
joining the string.
This corresponding
to two strings
joined into one string, and
this proportional to g0.
And this, from the field
theory point of view,
it just controls the
interaction of the three A's.
So that must be the
Yang-Mills coupling.
So this must be the
And then this should
be related to gs
to the power 1/2, which we
just derived slightly earlier.
So now, on dimensional ground,
the g Yang-Mills square
can be written as--
let me write it here.
This is an important formula.
On dimensional grounds,
the g Yang-Mills square,
I should be able
to write it as gs.
So on the Yang-Mills
coupling, we
will use the standard
convention that A
has the dimension of mass.
And then this is a
dimension 4 object.
And this is a
dimension p plus 1.
And so the Yang-Mills
coupling, you
can deduce the dimension of
the Yang-Mills coupling there.
And it just turns out to
be p minus 3 dense-- again,
because alpha prime in string
theory is only length scale.
So the alpha prime
must come from here.
And then times some constant.
So again, dp is just
some numerical constant.
And you can see explicitly
that when p equal to 3,
then you have d3 brane.
Then the world volume
theory is four dimensional.
Then we recall that
in four dimensions,
Yang-Mills theory
is dimensionless.
QCD [INAUDIBLE].
Good?
Any questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: What to do with phi h?
HONG LIU: Hm?
HONG LIU: What to do with phi h?
What do you mean what
to do with phi h?
AUDIENCE: Scalar
color particles?
HONG LIU: Yeah.
I forgot to mention here is the
standard derivative, covariant
derivative.
So the alpha phi a is just
the standard particle phi
a minus i a alpha phi a.
So it's the standard gauge
covariant derivative.
AUDIENCE: Shouldn't phi be more
fundamental presentation of--
HONG LIU: No.
Everything is to the
join because everything
has two ends.
AUDIENCE: So how to
interpret phi, then, in our--
HONG LIU: Hm?
AUDIENCE: From the present
zoology of particles,
where to put phi, the
observed particles?
HONG LIU: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: If a is just the
gauge boson [INAUDIBLE]
or something, what is phi?
HONG LIU: Phi is
some scalar field
transformed on the join
representation of the gauge
group.
It's a matter field describing
the motion of the brane.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
There you say that we can
reshuffle their indexes.
So that symmetry should
be permutation symmetry?
HONG LIU: No.
AUDIENCE: Why [INAUDIBLE]?
HONG LIU: But I reshuffle
because I say it
in the more heuristic way.
But normally, if the indices
is not-- these are the states.
And you can just
swivel-post them.
A different i, they
should be the same thing.
They're just corresponding to
relabeling, I'm just saying.
The lateral action of anything
on the state, of course,
is the unitary transformation.
AUDIENCE: Is there
anything to do with that?
HONG LIU: No.
That thing is
related to this star,
why we put this star here.
This is the reason why
we put the star there,
because the two
endpoints, they should
transform in opposite way.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Since the
branes become dynamical,
can't they fluctuate
in different ways
and so no longer coincide?
HONG LIU: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Since the
branes are dynamical,
you put them all in
one place at first.
But can't they now start
fluctuating and separate?
HONG LIU: They can certainly.
AUDIENCE: They're
no longer symmetric.
They become distinguishable.
HONG LIU: They can
certainly start
moving apart if you give
them some initial motion.
But the fluctuation,
the system is isotropic.
There's no place for them
to-- they will fluctuate,
but they will still at
that point on average.
There's no preferred
direction for them
to go unless you give
them a direction.
You say, I want them to
go in that direction.
Then you push them.
AUDIENCE: But you
can still think
of them fluctuating
kind of separately,
separating in
their fluctuations?
HONG LIU: Sure.
This a are their fluctuations.
Phi are their fluctuations.
AUDIENCE: Is this commutative
term belonging to the effective
action an interaction between
the D-branes or is it--
HONG LIU: Yeah.
Good point.
Let me just comment
on this term.
So if you think about
it, as we said before,
a D-brane, no matter
what dimension
of the D-brane, the story
when we quantize them,
they're almost the same.
It's the same spectrum.
If you have a
space-feeling brane
that everything is
A alpha, and then
if you have some lower
dimensional brane, some of them
become scalar field, et cetera.
So essentially, they all
have the same dynamics.
So this interaction can be
considered just come from here.
So you can start with a
space time feeling brane,
and then you go to
lower dimensions.
And then this just can be
considered to come from there.
It's part of the gauge theory.
AUDIENCE: So the whole
low energy actions
are the action of supergravity
plus this D-brane interaction,
you can think of the
whole low energy action?
HONG LIU: You mean if you
include the closed string?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
HONG LIU: Yeah.
That's right, if
you have D-branes.
That's right.
This is effective
action on the D-brane.
This is the effective
AUDIENCE: I mean if you
extend D-brane [INAUDIBLE],
then where does this
action come from?
HONG LIU: No, that's
what you said.
AUDIENCE: It's just two
actions crossed together?
HONG LIU: Yeah.
Good?
AUDIENCE: Excuse me.
How come it has the
term in action that's
proportional to phi
without derivative?
HONG LIU: No.
They have derivative.
This is covariant derivatives.
AUDIENCE: The commutator.
HONG LIU: No, but phi have
covariant derivatives.
AUDIENCE: But the next time.
HONG LIU: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: That thing appears
to be proportional to phi
without derivative.
HONG LIU: Yes?
AUDIENCE: But this is the
Minkowski space or something.
HONG LIU: Yeah.
That's a very good point.
I'm going to mention that point.
But the key is that this
particular potential-- this
is a very good point.
I'm going to mention that.
I will mention that
in a few minutes.
I do because I do want
you to do your p-set.
So now let's consider
separating the branes.
Now we will consider
Again, let's consider
the situation
we just have two of them.
So at the beginning,
they're coincidental.
And then now let's separate
them in some direction.
Let's call that direction x.
So let's say they separate
by some distance, d.
This is 1, this is 2.
So of course, this 1, 1
and 2, 2 string, nothing
changes because they're just
still ending on the same brane.
But those strings
are now different.
So now 1, 2 and 2, 1
strings become different.
So 1, 1, 2, 2, exactly
the same as before.
And the 1, 2 string.
For example, let's
consider the 1, 2 string.
Then the boundary
condition changes
in the way I have sigma equal
to 0, say, in the x direction.
Sigma equal to 0.
Tau, say, is at some location.
Let's call this x0.
And then x sigma equal to pi
tau then becomes x0 plus d.
So now it means when
you contact this string,
you have to do a slightly
modified boundary condition.
So you have start
with x equal to 0.
Now you must include a
term depend on sigma.
And again, as before,
we take the xL
to be minus xR and
periodic, et cetera.
So for sigma equal to 0,
then this boundary condition
is satisfied.
But in order to satisfy the
boundary condition at pi,
then you now need this w
equal to d divided by pi.
You need to develop
d divided by pi.
So now, you have a sigma term.
So that will change your
[INAUDIBLE] condition.
So remember the
[INAUDIBLE] condition
we had before is something like
this, q alpha prime p minus,
say, is p plus 4 pi alpha prime.
Say for the open string.
I'm writing the
open string version,
which is, up to some numerical
factor, the same as closed
string we wrote down before.
So now, because of
this term, then there's
additional contribution
on the right hand side.
It makes sense
because now string
has to be stretched
over some distance.
That costs energy.
So take one minute
to do it yourselves.
Just plug this into here.
You only need to look at
the behavior of this term.
Just plug in there.
Take you, say, five seconds.
You find that the
massless condition now
has one more term plus
the rest, as before.
And that means now all the
previously massless particle,
this here with the
corresponding a alpha and phi a,
are no longer massless.
Because previously,
they were massless
because those terms are 0.
But now you have one more term.
And they have a mass
given by M divided
by d divided by 2 alpha prime.
Just take the
square root of that.
And because this is precisely
the d times the string tension,
because 1 over 2 pi alpha
prime is the string tension.
So this is exactly the
energy we expect, just
from a classical picture.
You have a string
stretched between the two.
Then this is the tension times
the length of the string.
So now you can also
easily understand
what's going on from field
theory point of view.
And now you only have two
sets of massless modes
now rather than four.
So what's happening is that now,
the gauge symmetry is broken
from u(2) to u(1) times u(1).
So the separation of
the branes essentially
corresponding to
the Higgs mechanism
in the following sense.
When you separate
the brane, I said
before phi should be
interpreted as the [INAUDIBLE]
location of the brane.
But you separate the brane.
That means one of the
five fields corresponding
to the x-- the x is in
the transverse direction
for the brane.
One of the five fields
corresponding to the x
must develop expectation value.
And that expectation value
then gives rise to this mass.
So this is precisely
a Higgs mechanism.
So now let's go
back to the question
what this potential term
means, whether we can actually,
as we said before, because
of the translation symmetry,
in principle, we can
pull the brane anywhere.
And now, I'm out of time.
So let me just say, if you
look at this potential,
this becomes 0 precisely
when phi a and phi b all
become commutes.
So that means we can diagonalize
the phi corresponding to all
the transverse directions.
You can diagonalize
phi corresponding
to all the transverse
directions.
And then they correspond
to the location
you put all your branes.
Go do your p-set, and you will
see a more explicit discussion
of this.
And then one final remark.
At the beginning, you started
with n branes together.
And then because of this,
we can separate them.
So we can find a solution
which, say they commute.
We separate them into different
stacks, n1, n2, n3, et cetera.
So this corresponds to
the configuration of phi.
So let me just write
all phi as a vector.
Say there's a1, n1 of
them at location a1,
and n2 of them at
location a2, and ak.
If I separate them into n
stacks, then will be like this.
So n1 of them at location a1,
and n2 of them at location a2.
You can check.
So this is n1 times
n1 identity matrix.
This is n2 times n2.
And you can check that such
a configuration does satisfy
this condition so
that you actually
can separate the brane
into such configurations.
And in this case, then
the gauge symmetry
is broken into u
n1 times u n2 times
u nk, because only those points
[INAUDIBLE] parts survives.
And all the other strings
between them become massive.
OK.
Let's stop here.